It's now
been 12
days since she disappeared,
and there is still no sign
of the Massachusetts mother of three
Anna Walsh, as the search
is intensifying for her.
Investigators are turning their
to her husband's past.
Court documents show that Brian
was described as a sociopath
and untrustworthy
during a 2019 legal dispute
over his father's estate.
CNN's Jason
Jason Carroll is live in Massach
this morning for CNN this mornin
Jason,
I know that they are basically
going through
essentially every part of his pa
with a fine tooth comb.
He's pleaded
guilty, not guilty
to a charge of misleading
investigators
about his whereabouts around the
she disappeared.
What are they looking at right n
and where actually is he right n
Well, right now he is in custody
state custody,
where he will remain
until we get more information
about
how that investigation is procee
You were talking about those cou
documents really
after combing
through a number of those court
documents.
Caitlin,
there were a number of red flags
there that we saw
where basically Brian Walsh
was accused back in 2019 of stea
money from his father
and being prone to violence
as investigators are now
in the process of testing items
that could be connected
to the disappearance of Anna Wal
A clearer picture is emerging of
husband, Brian,
and his troubled financial past.
Court documents show
he was involved in a bitter
legal battle over his father,
Thomas Walsh, his estate friends
as well as Walsh's nephew,
alleging in sign affidavits.
The elder Walsh and his son
had been estranged for years
after Brian Walsh
absconded with almost $1 million
Thomas Walsh.
Court records also say
because of the alleged theft,
it required Dr.
Thomas Walsh to continue
working past the age
at which he had wished to retire
as a significant amount of his s
were stolen and never returned.
And that's part of the reason wh
these court documents say
Walsh his father
cut his only son out of his will
in the years before his death in
Despite that, Walsh took steps
to take control of his father's
while saying in a sworn affidavi
he and his father had been estra
several times over the years,
but says they mended their relat
Ultimately, Walsh's
legal efforts were unsuccessful.
A judge ruled against him,
but those same documents
revealed more information
about Walsh's past,
including that at some point
he had checked himself
into a mental health facility.
His father's friends calling him
a sociopath in court documents
dated in 2019,
saying Ryan is not only a sociop
but also a very angry
and physically violent person.
I want nothing to do with him.
These allegations surfaced years
before Walsh pleaded guilty
to federal charges of selling fa
Andy Warhol paintings.
The victim of the fake sale sayi
Walsh was very convincing.
He was a very calculated
almost genius about how he went
about things
that troubled pass,
only increasing the scrutiny
around the disappearance of his
A bloody knife found
inside the family home.
Law enforcement
sources telling CNN a hacksaw
and cloth materials
with apparent blood stains
found at a nearby trash facility
The couple's friends say
nothing seemed out of the ordina
during a New Year's Eve celebrat
But now coming to terms
with what could be the outcome
they had feared.
I keep praying that
in all these trash
facilities, that facility
that she's not found there.
And really so that, you know,
we do have somewhere to go to,
to honor her and life
and for her children to
have somewhere to go to honor he
If someone did do something
to honor Walsh
in Massachusetts,
the law does not
necessarily require prosecutors
to show a motive for a crime.
Prosecutors like to be able
to show a motive.
Again,
I think it makes more sense to p
if there is a motive,
but as a matter of law, it's not
to prove a motive.
In most cases,
and Kaitlynn,
obviously,
there is a great deal of concern
for Anna Walsh's three children.
Right now.
They're in the custody
of the Massachusetts Department
of Children and Families.
Meanwhile, the park
where I'm standing right now,
this will be the scene
of a candlelight vigil for anima
That will be later this afternoo
Caitlyn Moore
thinking of her friends and fami
Jason Carroll, thank you so much